y hemos intentado encontrar a las mejores personas posibles,
mayormente fallamos en lograr lo mejor de ellas.
¿Cómo desarrollamos las habilidades que necesitamos?
Porque hace falta habilidad y práctica, también.
Si no vamos a tenerle miedo al conflicto,
tenemos que verlo como una forma de pensar
y luego tenemos que conseguir ser realmente buenos en ello.
Recientemente, trabajé con un ejecutivo llamado Joe,
que trabajaba para una compañía de equipos médicos.
Joe estaba muy preocupado por el equipo en que estaba trabajando.
Pensaba que era demasiado complicado
y que su complejidad
generaba márgenes de error que realmente podrían lastimar personas.
Tenía miedo de hacer daño a los pacientes que intentaba ayudar.
Pero cuando miró alrededor de su organización,
nadie parecía preocuparse en absoluto.
Así que él realmente no quería decir nada.
Después de todo, tal vez sabían algo que él no sabía.
Tal vez parecería un tonto.
Pero seguía preocupado
y tanto, que llegó hasta el punto en
que pensó que lo único que podía hacer
era renunciar al trabajo que amaba.
Al final, Joe y yo encontramos una manera
para que planteara sus inquietudes.
Y lo que sucedió entonces es lo que casi siempre
sucede en esta situación.
Resultó que todo el mundo tenía exactamente las mismas
preguntas y dudas.
Así que ahora Joe tenía aliados. Podrían pensar juntos.
Y sí, hubo mucho debate y conflicto
y discusiones, pero esto permitió que todos alrededor de la mesa
fueran creativos, solucionaran problemas,
y que modificaran el equipo.
Mucha gente pensaría que Joe era una
especie de soplón,
excepto que, a diferencia de casi todos los soplones,
él no era para nada un oportunista,
era un devoto apasionado de su empresa
y de los propósitos superiores que ésta buscaba.
Pero había tenido mucho miedo al conflicto,
hasta que finalmente fue mayor su miedo al silencio.
Y cuando se atrevió a hablar,
descubrió mucho más dentro de sí mismo
para aportar al sistema, de lo que él nunca había imaginado.
Y sus colegas no creen que sea un oportunista.
Lo ven como líder.
Así que, ¿cómo podemos tener estas conversaciones más fácilmente
y más a menudo?
Bueno, la Universidad de Delft
exige que los estudiantes de doctorado
tengan que presentar cinco informes que estén preparados para defender.
Realmente no importa el contenido de los informes,
lo que importa es que los candidatos estén dispuestos y sean capaces
de enfrentar a la autoridad.
Creo que es un sistema fantástico,
pero creo que dejarlo para candidatos a doctorado
es para muy pocas personas y muy tarde en la vida.
Creo que tenemos que enseñar estas habilidades
a niños y adultos en cada etapa de su desarrollo,
si queremos tener organizaciones que piensen
y una sociedad pensante.
El hecho es que la mayoría de las grandes catástrofes de las que hemos sido testigos,
rara vez vienen de información que es secreta u oculta.
Vienen de información que está disponible libremente pero
a la que somos intencionalmente ciegos,
porque no podemos o no queremos afrontar
el conflicto que esto provoca.
Pero cuando nos atrevemos a romper ese silencio,
o cuando nos atrevemos a ver,
y creamos el conflicto,
nos habilitamos a nosotros y quienes nos rodean
para nuestro mejor pensamiento.
La información abierta es fantástica,
las redes abiertas son esenciales.
Pero la verdad no nos liberará
hasta que desarrollemos las habilidades, el hábito, el talento
y el coraje moral para utilizarla.
La apertura no es el fin.
Es el comienzo.
(Aplausos)